as a child I I was you know I had an
accent I came to us at the age of six
and I'm sorry STIs and stuff in
elementary school even when you go after
a more ambitious goal even if you fail
to achieve that one all the side effects
that come along the way can be that much
more rewarding and significant I think
you should have fun and not be so
weighed down by the weight of
expectations need motivation watch a top
ten of belief nation what's up at seven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's lessons from a man who went from
emigrating from the Soviet Union at the
age of six and being bullied as a boy
because of his thick Russian accent to
founding Google and becoming one of the
wealthiest people in the world is Sergey
Brin and here's my take on his top ten
rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite take a
shot could you ever imagine what what
came out of your original
entrepreneurial steps no I could not
possibly have imagined but you know and
I don't know what your thinking was
behind the form but I remember when I
was really thinking deeply about this
and this was sort of a you know a
graduate student project at Stanford and
I you know I talked to my advisers like
you know should I really do this
entrepreneurial thing and you know might
not work out and I could just finished
my PhD and he said you know why not go
for it and then if doesn't work out you
come back you finish your PhD which I'm
still planning on doing but anyway you
know there's like no big deal just give
it a shot and and I think that that
mentality permeates Silicon Valley and I
think that's one of those strengths that
you know there's really not much it's
not viewed so negatively to try
something even if it doesn't work out
rule number two
love the process you've made ginormous
announced money what do you guys plan on
doing the rest your life you've achieved
so much already I think you know there
are many important things to life you
know aside from financial or career
success
[Music]
and in fact it's not necessarily the
ultimate success that motivates you it's
the process of getting there and the
technologies or products that you build
or in whatever realms you may be and so
I'm not too concerned about finding
something to do though I do think it'll
be based on doing things that I really
enjoy and not have some end goal in mind
rule number three find your passion
eventually I went on to to join the ph.d
program computer science at Stanford and
those purely you know the interest of
what can you do with all the world's
information now that it's online that
interest spawned Google and that was
together with Larry Page who's my
co-founder and partner I think as a kid
I was I always had kind of scientific
curiosity
I was always interested in mathematics
and I was I always enjoyed doing math
problems and in fact my undergrad I had
a degree in both math and computer
science and I think eventually I was
really inspired by computers because of
the amazing power that they they give
you I mean today's PCs do a billion
operations per second I mean it's almost
inconceivable and I think that was the
most inspiring thing to me how you could
leverage that to actually produce
something that was you know those useful
beyond videogames and things like that
rule number four make a difference the
challenge of a problem are the
importance isn't that related to how
likely you are to achieve it and and in
fact even when you go after a more
ambitious goal even if you fail to
achieve that one all the side effects
that come along the way can be that much
more rewarding and significant in their
own right
and so you know I feel lucky that I fell
into doing something but I feel really
matters you know getting people
information around the world about
anything I I wish there was a way to
convey that to you know to the world at
large obviously all of you
already have this religion but it's very
rewarding when you work on something you
think it's gonna make a big difference
and yeah it's a little bit harder but I
think I think the passion that one might
bring with it brings so much more energy
to that that you're more likely to
succeed rule number five find good
partners
I'm Sergei Brett I'm from Google and
prior to that I was a PhD student at
Stanford Larry and I first met when he
came to visit during the the PhD
recruitment weekend which was he started
a couple of years after I did and we
became good friends when when he
actually agreed to join and came on
board and we experimented with a variety
of things you know we had some shared
interests and Larry had this crazy idea
that he was gonna download all the links
on the web and then do something with
them it wasn't entirely clear what we
did find that there were great
applications
oh and one of them was search which
eventually became Google co-founders are
super important for building a company
and you guys have doing great for 15
years have you sort of like
fundamentally disagreed on something at
all or or the last 15 years and how did
you go how do you resolve where do I
start
no I think if you get to know somebody
or a long period if I we're working
together for so long and we you know are
committed to doing that you don't like
it agitated about one little thing or
the other I know we work it through in
also generally we've gotten to think
remarkably alike which scares some
people around us I guess yeah and the
other thing I mean we know no focus that
we're disagree I mean you make a lot of
calls that aren't obvious so I mean if
you're disagreeing it's probably that
it's not obvious what to do rule number
six overcome challenges one is on
playing a service that's going to serve
millions of people when we
at Stanford we had you know 10,000
people using our service or about 10,000
searches per day I should say and now we
serve over 50 million searches per day
and that's scaling of infrastructure
that that's pretty challenging on a more
personal level I think I'm now the
president of Google and we have about
170 people now and I think managing
managing people and being emotionally
sensitive and all the skills you learn
in terms of communication and keeping
people motivated I think you know that's
been a challenge and I've enjoyed
learning that but that's that's an
important and a hard thing to learn rule
number seven fail quickly the other
thing that we've really found over time
at Google Washington other companies
watching many of you is the importance
of the development cycle and how you
really need to be able to turn quickly
through things and because you know
obviously you're going to have failures
you're going to have the wrong idea but
it's important to fail quickly rule
number eight silence the noise I think
young people you know in some ways their
their life is much easier than you know
sort of my life might have been at that
stage just you know for I think all of
us you know having before whatever if we
were traveling to Switzerland it would
be a big stressful thing how do you get
in touch with people before mobile
phones arrange your travel figure out
how to exchange your currency you know
there are many things you know we can
whip our phones out and look up anything
and figure out how to get somewhere
there are a lot of affordances that are
such convenes as today that make it easy
but there is also a global stage that
makes it hard actually you know because
if when I was in school and I was on the
math team or whatever Orosz just
compared to other kids in the school and
I did quite well against
you know and I found myself yeah I'm
good at that I'm good at that I think I
find younger folks today are there
measures of themselves are always
especially you know the ambitious ones
on this global stage instead like well
you know I have to be number one in the
world at this or that never like you
know that's a really tall order
and I think it can be discouraging in a
way because of you know you know the
folks say well you know I'm number 1,000
on the world of this gate which which
you know in my world would have been an
enormous achievement because that means
like you were definitely the best in
like your city in your state and whatnot
but but it's it's hard and and I think
you know they get there's a little bit
of discouragement so you know I would
encourage young folks to you know take
chances and pursue their dreams and you
know try to silence out kind of the
voice does that say well actually there
are like a thousand startups trying to
do whatever self-righting bicycles or
whatever it is they happen to be doing
are nice things the keys to have fun in
your startup or not how's the beginning
on to think of the IPO which raping your
billion sets keep and said well
certainly know your motivation to make
it a success yeah I mean I certainly had
no dreams such economic success and I
think you're exactly right I think you
should have fun and not be so weighed
down by the weight of expectations that
I think sort of this global network
unfortunately one of the downsides I
think it creates that weight rule number
nine
be grateful as a child I I was you know
I had an accent I came to the u.s. at
the age of six and I'm sorriest East's
and stuff in elementary school and I
don't think I was I don't regard myself
as you know being really popular going
through school but I that was never that
important to me and I always had friends
I think if anything I've
and I feel like I've gotten a gift by by
being in the States rather than going up
in Russia and I know the hard times that
my parents went through there and I'm
very thankful that that I was brought to
the states and I think it just makes me
appreciate my life much more and rule
number 10 the last time before two very
special bonus clips is have fun sir have
you a shower yet today I not not in this
temperature water no new glares over
here okay yet why don't we invite some
nooglers okay well Larry you have my
microphone first of all Jesus that was
very refreshing yeah that was worse than
I expected I'll be honest about who view
over faster than that but it kind of
sticks on you here it's like kind of
still feels really released we actually
had ice yeah yeah I know no this is
legit this the real deal anyway we'll be
making a donation to ALS and I know we
should talk some other executives I
can't think of who I want to make suffer
right now so well keep that in mind
now I've got two very special sergey
brin bonus clips around how to solve
problems and believe in your mission but
before that I want to hear from you what
did you guys learn from this video what
are you gonna apply to your business or
your life somehow
don't just watch another video but do
something about it and write it down
when you write it down in the comments
you're much more likely to actually take
action on it so I'd love to hear your
thoughts leave it in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love much love how
do I end it
much love I'll see you soon much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
certainly anyone can say oh I want to
build you know a car that's gonna cost
five dollars and go 500 miles an hour no
that would be great
I was fortunate to be at Stanford and I
was really interested in data mining
which means analyzing large amounts of
data discovering patterns and trends and
at the same time Larry joined Stanford
in 95 and he started downloading the web
which is it turns out to be the most
interesting data you can possibly mine
and our joint effort just looking at the
data out of out of curiosity we found
that we had technology to do a better
job of search and from that initial
technology we got really interested in
the problem and we realized how
impactful having great search can be and
so we built technology upon technology
after that to bring Google to where it
is today and we continue to develop lots
of technology for tomorrow Larry and
Sergey almost got acquired can you tell
us a little bit about this and I always
wonder what the world how the world
might be different if that had in fact
happened well we had developed this
technology we called PageRank sadly not
in rank but anyway you probably would
have sold better that way
but um we had developed this technology
that we found was useful for search it
by itself it wasn't really a complete
search engine what we had kind of just
search titles of webpages and and ranked
them quite well but we showed it to a
bunch of the existing search campaigns
back then some of you might remember
them Infoseek excite Lycos and probably
the greatest interest came from excite
and actually came from the node you were
the the industr and excite and we spent
a while talking to them Talya and
talking talking to you Vinod yeah you
remember that in the end I don't think
the management team there was quite as
excited about it no pun intended
but I remember we were you know we were
just there were four guys of us at the
time for grad students at Stanford and I
remember we fired off a note to the note
was just like a little email said like
you know we don't really want to sell
but okay for 1.6 million dollars you got
a deal and a few minutes later we got a
reply and said that's a lot of dough but
okay we'll do it I know that's
characteristic vinod right so then ten
minutes later Scott one of the four of
us comes running in laughing a huge grin
on his face he had faked the reply and
[Laughter]
yeah back then you know they ethics
around faking you weren't quite the same
anyway so here at that big joke and the
deal obviously never came to fruition
and we went our own way to Bill told
search so the way I remember it we
actually agreed on a deal around
$350,000
trying to renegotiate the snow a hard
time getting the management team to
agree that they should acquire Google I
think he's saying that they were having
our time going to 350 and we have a hard
time changing our number yeah that they
felt they didn't need it out but you
know I start here for one very simple
reason there are many many instances
where things could have gone either way
and I'm really glad they didn't acquire
because the world might have been a very
very different place looking back in
retrospect I feel like it would have
been really really sad if in fact the
Larry and Sergey had sold the company
and not pursued the vision and changed
the way the world the way they have so I
pull it's actually kind of an
interesting story because the reason we
didn't sell it is not so much the money
I mean like I don't know we're like rats
toons
you know eating burritos or whatever so
like a million dollars was fair amounts
the reason I think we really didn't sell
that company was that we talked to all
the search companies at the time and
they just weren't interested in what
we're doing and so and it was obviously
like didn't wanna buy like you know this
company that didn't really have anything
without the people so they wanted Alice
but like we were like well why are we
going to work at this place that doesn't
believe in search yeah it's not gonna
cause anything good to happen something
ultimately we didn't sell for that
reason she said they weren't interested
in it which same reason they whatever
had trouble getting to a million dollars
which I guess at the time was a lot of
money but uh but I think ultimately for
me it was just about wanting to actually
go search seemed pretty important it was
about actually wanting to do something
in that area and didn't seem like that
was going to happen in these
organizations raise your standard Apple
at the core is core values
is that we believe that people your
passion can change the way people now
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's supposed to mean I don't
ever give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details